[Music]
trying to bring back the old school flow
like my name's Dave and I'm here to say
pull the beat up
welcome to the tour
initial first tour you supposed to go
hard this is the biggest event of the
Year man
I'm Ali this is no [__] on the bus
you [__] you split
how is the search for love going I mean
I had such high hopes this was supposed
to be like the Romantic climax of life
this is the scroll guard it is an STD
preventative tool oh wow you look great
I feel so protected
I'm so happy that I get to see America
for what it is you're like my favorite
rapper is that me it's concrete this is
the heaviest thing wow you're with him
every day how do you resist him to him
are you serious
because I'm with him every day
welcome to the Met Gala do some
adversity
bro you fall down seven times you get up
eight why would I have to get up eight
times if I've only fallen down seven the
math doesn't even add up
we just gotta control them I don't have
any control over Dave tour is just the
one time where there's no deadlines I
can just live life to the app
whoa please do not shoot USA USA
you don't know my values maybe we have
more in common than you might think why
don't you just tell me what they are
[Music]
uh mom what are our values
coffee for Jew Jew coffee for there you
go Jew
[Music]
that's the foot any pain what's wrong
that's the foot feels like we should be
happier any pain I want to make it do
happy people in bright colors
maybe it's one of those places that you
only go once and never return oh like
Soul cycle
Chicago
this is very different now our heroes
into the city of Chicago who is he
talking to at one point a lot of
musicals had narrators sorry go ahead
really do I have your permission uh oh
he's peppery
clearly we're in the next era of
musicals here we shock you these
musicals are darker
with more sex oh yeah and violence
[Music]
oh you gotta be kidding me
how are we supposed to make a happy
ending here these musicals don't have
happy endings
sounds like someone needs a lesson in
the power of Happiness who wants to get
naked what I need is a lawyer once I've
worked my magic no jury will ever
convict your hubby even if he kills
again Josh didn't do it uh-huh
[Music]
[Applause]
bouncing around
[Music]
Chicago
you too want a girl
need my help to answer that question no
thank you
[Music]
are you okay
foreign
[Music]
what is your problem what
oh man where are you at
what are you doing
sometimes
[Music]
I have a very full life that I'd love to
get back to I'm gonna find you and take
what little you have
[Music]
you're just a Suburban housewife and now
you're stuck in a life you never wanted
[Music]
you have this serenes and Buddhist thing
going on
[Applause]
hey
I'm a dangerous guy
so stop messing with me and leave me
alone or else
I would love to let this go uh actions
have consequences
I just can't understand what those
people are so angry about
[__] ass handyman pissing on my
hardwood floor this is European oh come
on
[Music]
ways to manage my stress you're born
choices
you're here
maybe we're not normal
maybe normal people are just delusional
[Music]
part of this me
me psycho you're the one that flipped me
off all right
are you guys leaving are you just gonna
sit there are you safe
foreign
[Music]
Belle would eat lunch with them today to
end the divisions Among Us I
he told me exactly what you did to get
that jacket
it's not as bad as it seems
these things blow over maybe for you
there are a lot of kids in Rydell who
are sick of feeling like they're not
welcome here I know what it feels like
to not be like the others
[Music]
we have to think big really change
things everyone
else for such bad girls watch out fellas
it's a girl game we're not girls we're
ladies the Pink Ladies
we're gonna need some jackets
pink lady pledge is
act cool to look cool and to be cool
till death do us part
think pink
[Applause]
the world's changing boys
[Music]
[Applause]
maybe sometimes you gotta be bad to do
good
[Music]
the world
how are you both great fine
Danny blasted porn on the Bluetooth
speakers
literally melted from overuse would you
believe me now if my life is a mess my
husband kicked me out a few days ago
my daughter hates me
oh my God Mom threesome is a big leap
maybe you were consciously worried about
our little threesome about what me and
you and Dad
how did I get so far from the person I
wanted to be
what would I tell my 22 year old self
worrying whether you're fat who gives a
[__]
stop obsessing about your nose your nose
is perfect don't take your mom for
granted she won't be here forever Blair
Marie Pierce is an award when
point oh
you're one of the best writers I know an
advice column is easy clicks okay take a
look you should be the one doing this
I'm not giving anybody advice
what would I
someday you'll look back on that one
Christmas when your mother gave you a
mustard yellow coat don't hold it up and
say it's too puffy because your mother
will be dead by Spring and that coat
will be the last gift she ever gave you
I wish you weren't my mom
could die tomorrow and if I did you
would never forgive yourself because
that would be the last thing that you
would ever said to me you're not the
only one that could die tomorrow so can
I
that is an awful thing to say to me
I want so much for you
but you're not gonna get any of it if
you don't want it for yourself
[Music]
what does it mean to heal to move on
to let go
[Music]
why can't you make new friends like what
happened to Bethany Bethany had anal sex
on a greyhound going to Reno what yeah
why would she want to take a bus to Reno
oh my God we've been to 1500 places and
my feet are freaking killing me please
tell me you don't hate this one too I
think I love it all right
it's the first time I felt like
celebrating my existence since I was 11.
happy birthday
[Music]
29. I can't believe it you are beautiful
even without makeup I have so much
makeup on
and it's perfect
I'm happy for you Sam most people sober
or not do not have a life that they are
proud of I have the first real job I've
had in years and I have a boyfriend
[Music]
Sam I don't think you're ready to be in
a relationship you don't you shouldn't
be asking me that question I shouldn't I
think you should get out of here you do
please stop sorry
[Applause]
I tried really hard if you make sobriety
your number one priority everything's
gonna fall into place you don't have to
go to meetings every single day yes
unfortunately I do
no drama it is my favorite thing in the
world
I'm sorry um so much
Carol can you control your daughter no I
can't
[Music]
are fallible
something bigger than we are to get
through this
I actually have a gift for you you ready
you were right
three best words in the English language
not I love you ew no
[Music]
hi I'm Mike
and I'm a gambler
lost my job plus my wife
I'm paying a phone like that by working
for the gangster you owe it to
gets home okay
he said this wasn't gonna happen again
probably was though
I need you to go and get her where did
she go Florida I'll bring her back I
walk away clean forever
fine
I'm tracking down this woman my employer
is concerned for the woman's safety but
so am I
this woman you're looking for should
want to be found no I'm an old time
criminal adjacent
well then maybe you should talk to a
criminal
you don't bring your trouble into my
neighborhood son
[Music]
ick how are you gonna get a gun this is
Florida the goddamn state is shaped like
a gun
aren't you glad to see me Mike
your fortunes due for a turn
I'm talking about 100 million dollars
we're here to join forces
I'm running this show we do it tonight
or never
I'll put a man found out the hard way
when the hunter became the hunted these
are serious people you need to leave do
you not have a compass Florida doesn't
have tracks and that is a bad
combination this ain't Disney World
anymore
[Music]
everyone in this whole place can go
ahead and kill each other
try to catch him anymore
[Music]
your transformation is now complete
your power will have no equal
my name is Brother Blood
and I'm going to change the world
[Music]
where are the Titans
maybe your friends are out there
just
in a different dimension
Titans aren't my friends
I do things Titans don't do
we have the same blood
he's connected to me feeding on me
I don't have much time
what are we toasting
the future
it's next we bring back your father
Give Me What You Got
You Learn by doing
I will not abandon the people I wrote
most
it's a matter of life and death for the
entire world
don't be afraid that wall connected to
me
foreign
[Music]
you say everything I think a terrifying
connection
seem to be experiencing very bad luck I
don't know about that
business is really picking up
it's a busy professional office now
what was it like so many dicks what
whatever ah too much talking boy are you
in the wrong family kid
not one person who's ever accomplished
anything of worth in life has ever been
happy
forward three steps back and I'm tired
of it this is it this is the break they
don't see you for what you are a goddamn
star
you win
I'm in it's show time
[Applause]
[Music]
what defines you
it finds you
I ask first
there's nothing I wouldn't do for my
daughter
Mrs Michaels Mr reckles asked me to give
this to you
[Music]
sorry ma'am the building's closed my
husband works inside I'm trying to reach
him
I haven't heard from Owen in 24 hours
where's my dad
I don't know what is that
okay
this is happening your husband that's
not who you think he is why are you
making him sound like some criminal
mastermind I may not know why your
father did what he did but I know who he
is he lied to me then he disappeared and
I want to know the truth
I'm telling you we'll find him
[Music]
now
where did you get this
tell me who sent you go now
stepdaughter or an imminent danger is
that something you're not telling me
they need to stay together
[Music]
see you in two weeks for the first
family visit yes you will
when you get here in two weeks we are
about to everybody can hear you on
speakerphone
[Music]
things are tough I get that you could
stand to be a little more fun I'm fun
it's time to
do today she's terrifying
[Music]
I want to hang with Dad oh no no go over
man
my Mom feels so good to be out doing
some normal ass [__]
you know Ash been on one
[Applause]
you won't believe what she has done
[Music]
this may be the cleanser that sends
himself throwing her a pass if she
pressed against
sometimes it just is what the [__] it is
[Music]
black
I felt that on the other side
[Music]
I'm really sorry
I didn't think it would end up like this
I am a good person
that is who I am you better run
for your life
you're irredeemable
the guy I was dating in L.A killed my
acting teacher's girlfriend
I think I might be in a lot of trouble
you're irredeemable
and it's our chance
[Music]
very betrayed me I showed him how I
really felt and he betrayed me
[Music]
Bergman you got a visitor
I'm trying to change
[Music]
everything okay
yeah
everything's gonna be great
you better run
for your life
okay
is it okay if I proxy
sorry she'll speak to me through here
and then I'll just repeat whatever she
says not she
it
is a machine she wants to talk talk talk
talk to you if I say no it's just gonna
send someone else isn't it probably you
are the only person on the planet who
can fulfill this Quest
you must locate
Holy Grail
so what now
Miss Davis is all-knowing and
all-powerful
she not only knows you're coming for her
wants you to
[Music]
Wiley what is that on your face
oh let's change the time I saw you meet
resistance are you resisting same thing
you are yeah
Mrs Davis don't give it a nine
no one calls Facebook Doug
this is what it does everyone you meet
is only trying to push you into doing
what it wants
it's just a matter of time before every
person on Earth does whatever it asks
them to
the best weapon you've gotten
[Music]
hey Mom
let's party
[Applause]
hello
hi
um I'm looking for the Grail
with the Holy One
[Music]
come and get it so much new business
check it out so when are you gonna put
those needles in you're cool
so much new Butthead yeah maybe my soul
is like full of rain and stuff
Parenthood is cool it's 4 20. everyone
hold hands uh hold hands guys all right
so many all-new reasons
to stay on the couch I'll let the games
begin an all new season of Beavis and
Butthead streaming April 20th I Now
pronounce you husband and husband this
is the happiest day of my life
exclusively a Paramount plus it's
impossible to explain this relationship
to anyone outside of it we just cut a
baby out of a woman's womb she asked us
to we didn't just like do it she's the
funny one
my sister and I do work that is
groundbreaking hopeful radical but safe
[Music]
I want to change the way that women
it is world changing how does that
vomit-inducing idealism translate into
dollars I do my job to help people baby
sister who are so deliciously perfect
where do you come from
capital
is very bad
[Music]
you're okay oh I'm brilliant
you want me to throw you a baby out of
nothing bring it on let's do the
research let's make anything happen
oh God
it's not what we what we're doing though
but it might be but it's not but it
could be but it's not what Frankenstein
from uh are you up to
really like her what she means none of
your business everything's my business
not this
[Music]
they're both brilliant they're both
liabilities we are extraordinary
you're a psychopath oh well if I'm the
psycho you're a psycho we are as close
to
Shin as you can get that is just nuts I
love it
I don't need anyone else you never have
you were looking really crazy for a
while there as it turns out I'm really
saying isn't that wonderful
foreign
[Music]
how do you think they're going to react
when we tell them they can't leave
I know this sounds crazy but none of you
are safe here whoa whoa what the hell is
she talking about we are all in this
thing together
there are things around here that walk
and talk just like us until they walk up
to you and rip your guts out
there was no way out
oh thank God we heard the screaming
you picked a bad spot
I need to do whatever I can to get these
people home
[Music]
but if all this was designed just to see
how we react
[Music]
what if it's all dressed a dream
something happened to me out there I
don't understand
[Music]
fear is what makes us Heroes
seeing a lot of people
push to their Edge
you ever wonder if maybe that's the
point
[Music]
what's your dream lady I don't know okay
I'll go first I would wear something
really cute you know just festive but
not like white or Bridal because you
gotta keep them guessing you gotta keep
them good
and I would walk down the aisle to the
song Gloria by Laura Branigan
and of course in my childhood I dreamed
that I would fly her in to sing it but
now I have you
oh it's all you can't touch bran again
you can touch bran again no Barbara no
Judy no Branigan come on
Gloria Gloria oh I think they've got
your number Gloria I think they've got
the Alias Gloria they've been living now
there but you really don't remember
voices
[Music]
[Laughter]
help each other because
you could be something that I thought I
lost a long time
[Music]
hope
these past nine years have been dry
we have suffered immensely
as a country as a species
just a matter of time before the whole
world learns
drivers
our key to the Cure
and when that happens everyone will want
a pizza to you
the last man
they've got my kids
I need your help
my public taught me
if I saw a human
I should hide
[Music]
but I am done hiding
oh
can I trust you
of course
always
eight years ago you two were citadel's
top spines but we were double crossed by
one of our own and your memories were
erased
I brought you here because I need your
help I coached Little League
there's my guy
right now every agent around the world
is looking for YouTube
I think you have the wrong person
you remember
Mason Kane is dead whoever betrayed us
is readying for something cataclysmic
are we together I'm flattering yourself
Deborah
I'm exceptionally skilled at getting
Citadel agents to turn
Mason can never find out you told me to
trust you why would you trust me I'm
exceedingly untrustworthy I'm a spy we
were set up and there's no one else it's
just you and me
[Music]
everything you know
is a lie
[Applause]
[Music]
have you ever pushed that red button
pull it
but no
so what do you think would happen
nothing
[Music]
see your face
foreign
[Music]
it's my husband Dan Dan Alex Forest
I know him already
foreign
[Music]